whoa why did the room just start
spinning just a little like everything
just like tilted on Ax are we rolling do
you need to do you need to lay down for
a second let's get this let's get it
let's get it let's get it let's get it
on Cera going down I'm fine now it was
just kind of weird it was
[Music]
like welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life or long time I'm R and I'm dizzy
yeah so just moments ago right when we
rolled the cameras link said why is the
room spinning and uh just to give you a
couple just a review of the reactions uh
Jenna immediately got uh
concerned and began asking questions
like how much water have you had to
drink do you need to lie down Etc and
what I said was let's get this let's
roll right now he might faint we might
get it on camera well it's like the room
it's it didn't spin it like it's just
like all of a sudden it's like it's like
the Earth tilted on its
AIS and then I'm like huh why is wow
ever happening before and then I look
over at you and you're like clamoring to
like start the timer yeah
yeah this week at the round table of dim
lighting uh we are diagnosing my
vertigo I have you know you had vertigo
I've had a couple of things that have
happened to
me first of all many years ago I had
that thing where like uh I had an inner
like a a middle remember that middle ear
deposit I had like classic vertigo and
it it was caused by this like just like
a little piece of I'll call it a little
piece of sand like one of the floaty
things part of an Orbee inside of your
that never got out you know inside
inside of your ear you got these like
loops and I had to get my physical
therapist on the phone and like I did
this uh I did this special treatment
remember where of movements where yeah a
series of movements based on the
infrastructure of the ear where I got
the little piece of sand to Traverse
back to where it should have been and
that was I mean that was a permanent
piece of sand that's supposed to be in
the
air yeah like there's pieces of things
but there's not sand no it's like isn't
like a bird that takes and digests them
to like do something no it's a
biological piece of sand yes biological
pieces of stuff in there that are
actually what is helps
interpret balance I'm sure the ent's
listening are loving it just loving how
accurate this first of all shout out to
all the ent's listening I I got to I I
got to got to throw some love they got
three things to keep up with right I
mean you ears noses and throats that's
right Rhett that is what it stands for
what you think about it yeah I mean they
could just be a whole doctor and then it
could be like you could add more well
they don't ENT BS they don't even take
care of the mouth they take care of the
throat the whole part is for somebody
else's job yeah that's the denes job I
but right now I'm still I'm still
evaluating whether I'm all right so
thanks for your continued concern I
think I'm all right it was just kind of
we'll find out it was this year but like
you know when um when I went scuba
diving uh the next night I had like
inner ear middle ear Barrel trauma like
I could not clear I could not equalize
for uh two
days and that was very discombobulating
but that was my left ear and this is
this is kind of in my right ear so was
was the tilting of the Earth the same
thing that you had with the sand piece
missing moved the sand piece was um
spinning absolute spinning to the point
of like fast spinning wow not even
slow this is like you know if you have
too much to drink and all of a sudden
you sit up and then everything
just that's what this just felt like it
was kind of slow but I can still see out
of both my eyes I'm good well you know
I'm good we're here we're rolling I
think get it I mean I've been
snowboarding the past two days I do want
to tell you about that um I missed your
your post your delayed New Year's Eve
gratification party like the way later
than New Year's Eve New Year's Eve party
and I'm interested I have some questions
for you about that cuz Christy went to
it and told me about it yeah I'm
interested in her perspective because uh
I was I got some feedback from a couple
of people that I that intrigued me okay
um I do want to tell you about something
that I don't know if you you experienced
this yet in Los Angeles this particular
thing that I'm going to tell you about
but I know that you would like it bring
it then
um I love LA because there's always
things that you can find out about this
is a big town if you're not in La you
might not know that there has
been somewhat of a burger
Renaissance uhoh uh so I'm all years now
Los Angeles has become the place to get
the best burgers in the world I believe
now I believe that this burger
Renaissance is probably taking place in
multiple places in the United States but
there's a bit of a battle in Los Angeles
for the best Smash Burger right I a good
smash BG and I like all Burgers but
Smash Burger definitely my favorite
they're the best because they're they're
so thin like a I I'm just not a fan of
the thick burger and then you get a thin
burger and a slice of cheese and then
they then it's like if you want it thick
we'll just add another thin burger and
another slice of cheese well that that
is exactly what I experienced yesterday
as a matter of fact I mean I'm that
burger is still with me right now just
like your little piece of sand that's
moving around your ear that little
Burger is in my body moving around it's
turning into something much less
appealing I I don't want to talk about
that why do we always end up talking
about digestion we Sorry Smash Burgers
are my weakness it's I mean it may be my
favorite
food I don't I I don't I have a whole I
have a place so much better than pizza
to me like well okay don't speak sacr
son I know Christie would hate me for
saying that but is not my thing it's
well I get to a certain place and I
can't imagine putting anything better in
my mouth well in terms of
food and there's I there's this peak
that gets hit sometimes it's Pizza
sometimes it's chicken tick Masala
sometimes it's a Burger you know I I hit
the roof of possibility of culinary
enjoyment and I hit it yesterday and it
actually was the second choice so
Shephard has been telling me about a
place called burgers Never say die so if
you look at top 10 burgers in La you see
there's multiple trucks and there's you
know and in restaurants and best Smash
Burger I'm saying yes um and a lot of
them are like on the west side or like
getting into Hollywood and I was like or
West Hollywood I was like that's too far
for me and
um but he had spent some time with a
friend in uh the Los vus area and I
think this place is in Silver Lake this
Burger's Never say die and um I pick him
up and we're all ready to
go and uh you know I didn't like call
ahead or anything I didn't think about
the fact that it was a holiday they were
close closed oh they were closed huh and
I was disappointed but then I was like
Shephard we got a we got Smashburger on
the brain we've got to just find the
next one so I did a little search in the
area and up Pops you searched second
best Smash Burger in the area I just
searched Smash Burger on on Yelp and
this other place came up and I realized
at least on Yelp it had more reviews and
a higher rating
then Burgers Never say die and I saw the
name of it I was
like for the win which is a interesting
name for the win I've heard about this
place it's also on the lists let's go in
there I haven't been to either one of
these places I feel so stupid yeah you
are stupid yeah for not doing this and
so was I until yesterday
link uh for the wind open you would love
it oh it was so open did you take a
picture can you show me a picture uh I
was about take a picture but then I
realized that the pictures that I had
seen on the internet were better than
the one that I was about to take of
course um but the the signature of this
thing which I'll show you which you will
really really like onions um let me see
if I onions in the burger some of them
do that there's like a certain type of
smashed burger with the onions oh my
Lord so as you can see there's so much
the Patty comes out burger just like
spilling out of that brown the diameter
of the Patty is two in larger the radius
is one inch larger you understand how Di
and radius work and you want that edge
or the meat to be a little crispy and
you can get a single a double or a
triple I'm not a crazy person I got a
double and the thing as you were
describing about a double is that these
burgers are so thin I don't know how
they're still together but they just put
them on top of each other so you have
this a crazy amount of surface area for
like the you know whatever that happens
the Char on the grill yes and they serve
them all the same way
um Burger Grill chees grilled
onions um they're burger sauce yep which
is like probably like a their secret
Thousand Island type thing and
pickles and that's the only three things
they put on there now they've got like
ketchup and mustard and stuff that you
could like put on at your seat but you
know I'm not going to do that I'm not
going to defile it two things about
Smash Burgers that tell you that link
thinks they're amazing first of all
pickles I have never been a pickle
person like for all of my days eating
Big Macs and Big Mac ain't it ain't a
bad Burger I mean it's not I mean I
don't want to eat them all the time
because then you'll come to realize that
they're not a great burger but sometimes
if you get a good Big Mac it's not bad
but I've always don't don't just keep
showing me that's bacon I didn't get the
bacon one uh I don't I don't believe you
need bacon on because it's this is what
I'm getting at with the pickles I would
always take the pickles off my Big Mac
or any Burger because it's kind of
distracting but a really good Smash
Burger is so greasy and juicy that you
need something to cut it and pickles are
the perfect thing and I'm coming around
to the world of pickles because of it
this is the one it's so I mean it's just
oozing with this is exactly what my
coming off your screen dude Jamie this
is the one that I want you to so their
Instagram is for the win La paint you
want Jamie to paint it see that right
there can you do a painting yes I
actually what if I did a painting that
would be cool but I'll put it next to
that picture yeah that's the one I'll
take a little screenshot of that so
that's what my burger looked like I got
a burger I got fries and they had
milkshakes uh the chocolate was out I
got strawberry shepher got vanilla the
second thing that lets you know that
link is a Smashburger boy is I have gone
through the trouble to learn how to
prepare my
own yeah that's questionable no no I've
done the same thing I'm just saying that
what I'm a pretty dang good cook and I
can't get close to this I'm not saying
how good it is I'm just saying I have
put forth the effort to actually say I'm
going to make Smash Burgers for my
family hey kids you want to invite a
friend over I'm going to make Smash
Burgers for your friends as well and let
me let you consider an analogy real
quick uh I don't think you understand my
point if you go to Italy bragging if you
go to Italy and you see uh no you're not
bragging I'm just saying the reason that
I have stopped making Smash Burgers for
people in my life yeah um is that if you
go to Italy and you see Michelangelo's
David right wherever that is somewhere
yeah and uh you you look at it and you
you notice the incredible craftsmanship
and you notice the small penis and uh
the other parts of it that are just so
Exquisite and uh and then you say to
yourself I'm going to go back to my
house and I'm and I'm going to make this
that would be an asinine thing to think
right where you g to get the marble you
don't know you're not trained it's going
to take forever you don't have the time
just go and look at David when you want
to see David of all the things that I
don't cook which is
everything I love them so much that I
want to have it in my own house and I
want and I I feel like I could do it now
I do a decent to good you see how thin
the edges of this are you've never I
look at that you've never had a Smash
Burger in my house okay well I mean okay
but those are great the bun is perfect
those ingredients are perfect why is
anybody making a burger that's not a
Smash Burger there's people starting
burger
restaurants in different places and
they're not making these it's a
different thing link it's the best thing
yeah but it's like saying thin crust
pizza and deep dish pizza I see them as
different foods so I and we'll probably
get worn out a thick I have a preference
I like a Smash Burger better but if I go
to a restaurant and they have a thick
burger and that's the burger option and
everybody's like you got you'll love
this burger I've Loved many a thick
Burger I've Loved a lot of thick
Burgers but you know I've lusted after
Smash Burgers there's a little slight
difference but I appreciate both both
things and you don't have to worry about
does the chef think that it needs to be
like medium
rare like that burger we got last week
at lunch and it was a damn good burger
but it wasn't cooked enough even for me
yeah and I was just it wasn't medium
rare it was rare it was rare it was way
on the rare side you have to worry about
that with a SM you got to try it uh I'm
not I'm not a good judge of Milkshakes I
I'll just be I know that you have
particular opinions about milkshakes I'm
kind of like this good milkshake but I
don't like I don't judge milkshakes hard
so I can't tell you whether or not their
milkshakes are great their fries are
very much like In-N-Out going for for
the same thing in terms of thin uh you
need to put some salt on them probably
if you really want to have a good time
you need to eat them fresh kind of thing
the burgers are the thing that they have
perfected now I got to go to this
burgers and Never say die because
shepher was like I don't know which
one's better they're pretty similar
let's go there today I can't have two
burgers in a row man two days two
burgers lot of red meat what are you
trying to do to me you got to cut down
on the red meat maybe this is happening
other places in America I don't know but
it's happening in LA and it's like an
arms
race Le let's let's me and you have a
little Burger date next time we feel
like we've earned the right we're g to
go and get us one of these Smashburgers
it can be like our Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day is coming up um okay so
me and you are going to go to get a
burger on Valentine's Day yep for every
year for the rest of our lives Well I
this there might be a maybe we just need
a burger day maybe is there an
International Burger day I want I want
it to be Valentine's Day well I think I
might have plans with my wife well it
doesn't have to be on the day you know
me and Lily have a thing every
Valentine's Day and of course me and
Christy have something but the 14th is
not sacred to us oh okay it's as long as
it's is it's within the season the month
of February yeah then we can get our
burger and um you know what we have our
own little Burger Valentine's Day cuz if
we just have a burger date then it's
like y'all have a date it's like yeah
but it's Valentine's Day oh okay it's
a is that better okay uh yeah I mean
whatever you want makes it if if you
want to go get a burger in February and
you want it to be a Valentine's Day
thing that's awesome every year and I
want to look forward to it do we only
get to go get burgers in
February yeah it's a
baseline I we needed I need to know that
once a year it's going to happen I'm I'm
sitting a barow man we got to start
somewhere
I need to warn you how messy I got how
how messy my face got this beard this
beard and that burger I almost felt
embarrass I was glad I was facing the
wall let me that much that's the beauty
of us having this date is that we don't
we're not attracted to each other I got
and we don't care what each other look
like it's not well there's no romance
this is the thing it's not that I think
you're attracted to me PL platonic it
would be de see the amount of burger
sauce that got into my beard when I ate
that burger I think it would be
unappetizing I think I would need a face
away from you I don't look at or maybe
we go in shifts yeah yeah yeah you stand
outside while I eat there you go no
actually you eat first because I'm still
going to have Burger on my face when I
come back out I don't want you that to
be the last thing to see Go in all right
you go in I'm going to go in first you
go in after me that's how our date work
I mean I had to go get I had to find
water a napkin was not enough wait were
you in the desert you had to find water
I had to wet a napkin I had to make my
own wet wet wipe in order to get get out
of there without looking like a
[Laughter]
fool I I highly recommend so we'll our
Burger date we will eat the burgers in
shifts we will not be seen together
having a burger date what are you guys
doing we're on a Valentine's Day dat
well actually I mean he's in there right
now eating a burger I'll be in in a
little bit right
okay hey you guys speaking of love
speaking of Valentine's
Day this would be a wonderful thing for
you to for yourself or for the one that
you love it is the cotton candy Randy uh
what are we calling this it's a
Valentine's Day tea it's um I don't know
what you know it doesn't matter what you
call it it's a t-shirt this says will
you eat my chocolate uh from from Randy
I made it myself and I won't say how
right a little bit of gross but you know
us and here's the thing you can also get
like Valentine's card
postcards that are part of this
collection actually physically give
somebody this is a valentine available
at mythical.com
ear biscus has brought to you by better
help you know I've been married for
23 years yep she's done it she's done
the work um and I got to say
that Jesse and I talk a lot about how we
really enjoy our relationship right now
and I know for a fact that a big reason
for that is that a she started going to
therapy and then B she convinced me to
start going to therapy and C UHS we both
go to therapy now and I think that that
working on yourself has made our
relationship that relationships are not
easy but it's made uh our relationship
easier uh I definitely feel that have a
mirrored
experience with me and Christie but a
common misconception about relationships
is that they have to be easy to be be
quote right but sometimes the best ones
happen uh when both people put in the
work to make them great therapy can be a
place to work through the challenges you
face in all of your relationships
whether with friends work your
significant other or anybody we are huge
Advocates of therapy so if you're
thinking of getting on the therapy train
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge become
your own soulmate whether you're looking
for one or not visit betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com you know what I might I might get
emotional about this Jenna can you throw
me that box of um uh tissue nose tisue
isssue is it empty throw it I I don't
trust I don't want to hit a
camera you're in athletic mode today oh
son of a and
then right on Q Jenna about took out her
entire desk by trying to walk through it
to get back to athletic move though are
you dizzy
too I caught everything nothing fell
you're an ath very
[Laughter]
the only better timing that I've ever
seen uh I have to tell this story
because it reminds me so much of it and
this is you just experienced a fraction
of it was the time my brother-in-law
Chris had just been at my brother's
house and had repaired a broken rocking
chair a rocking chair that had been
completely like multiple pieces like an
antique an old one and he like spent
some time like 20 30 minutes or whatever
like piecing it back together and then
he sits in the chair and he starts
rocking in the chair and everybody's
like Chris you did it you made and then
his wife Ashley
says he's pretty handy and literally as
she finished the word handy the entire
chair collapsed and he fell to the floor
it was like it was like cartoon yeah
boom all the way to the floor rocking
chair everywhere he pretty handy
boom
it's one of my favorite moments in life
oh man that I have
experienced he is pretty handy though so
you're in uh you know we don't we don't
make a practice of commenting on each
other's um ensembles usually I mean well
we
don't but I
do Jenna but Jenna does you might be the
most likely to to do so you're in
athletic mode today yeah thank you I I
it's um to make myself go to the gym
after very oh yeah okay already in the
outfit I'm ready I'm going to go do it I
thought you might be a part of a
location scout today oh is what when I
saw you in the parking lot you were
waiting and I was like okay they must be
going in like lo location scouting
today I'm in like Mobility mode I like
that I like that I like to have
different different modes I'm coming off
of um two days of
snowboarding and um I want to tell you
about it because I just I have some
thoughts about it I went with Lincoln
and one of one of my boys from the
scooter Club one of the guys um fellow
snowboarder is also a snowboarder he had
plans to go with his daughter uh this
past weekend and then she had she had to
bail and so then he was like hey I got
this condo I'm still going I got another
bed does anybody else want to go and my
big Christmas present to myself was a
snowboard and Lincoln
big Christmas present was a
snowboard and actually the reason why we
bought snowboards was my friend will was
like talking it up because you know I'd
switched to
skiing many years ago when you decided
to switch to skiing and you were like
you know it's like this is going to this
is going to take us into our old age you
know it's like you can't be a
snowboarder forever you got to be skiing
is skiing is the future to be specific
for me for you I wasn't telling you that
you needed to switch but I was listening
I switched because of my back skiing
harder on the knees better on the back
snowboarding harder on the back easier
on the knees okay that might be a a
rough generalization but you fall on
your butt a lot and if you catch an edge
it like the way that it messes with my
lower back snowboarding I just kind of
had to give it up even though I really
liked it I liked it more than scheme I
felt like I wanted to make that
transition and you know it would be a
good time to do it along with you and
then where like the kidss were learning
kind of trying to learn how to ski and
this is like what over the past
decade maybe maybe eight years um but
then he was like the last spring break
trip that we took Lincoln and his
friends tried snowboarding and Lincoln
absolutely loved it and then I tried it
one day remember I told you and I was
like see if it would come back from like
all the years I snowboarded I've still
snowboarded a lot more years than I have
skied and was immediately still better
than skiing so I was like man this is
still more
fun so then my friend will was like you
know you can get a if you're getting a
snowboard kit now you can get one of
these where it's like you can step right
in like step on there's no straps you
just you just you got this nice boot
that then goes into this special binding
and it hooks in the heel and then hooks
on either side of your front your toes
the right and left so you just kind of
click in and then you don't have to sit
your butt down on the snow and like do
all the straps and all this stuff and if
that would be essential to me because
also the sitting down and then standing
up is in the snow is really hard on my
back as well so that's what we got how
do you how do you get out of it um
there's a little lever on the outside of
the back heel and you just pull it up
and let you have to bend down grab that
you just kind of you just you can do
that while you're still going you're
getting back to the lift and but you're
squatting down how you're squatting down
to do that no you just bend over I mean
how do you touch your heel you bend over
with the SK
bow yes you have to bend over yeah yeah
I'm just saying I try to minimize the
amount of that I pull the I'm just
gauging this for myself pull the lever
up on my back foot my trailing foot and
then your heel comes out and then you
twist your front feet and it comes out
and it's like the simp simplest thing
ever okay there's no getting used to it
like the first run that we took down the
mountain I was shaky because it had been
almost a year since I've snowboarded
like you know you got to get your mojo
back did you bust at all the first time
you did it did you
bust no because you're just going slow
and like keeping yeah just taking it
easy um but it was there wasn't a
material difference in the experience of
like these step on versus like having
normal bindings like super happy with
it and and the boots that you're you're
in are they stiffer than a normal
snowboard boot yeah a little bit but
they're not like a ski boot the ankles
are not stiff no no no just the bottoms
just like you tighten I mean you want it
to be very
rigid and very tight but like the way
that you have these like this boa system
is what they call it where it's like
wires that like you like crank down
these knobs and it like pulls it all
together and like the technology is just
amazing and so it was very exciting to
have these things and like to try out
our our Christmas gifts and we're on the
lift and
like um Lincoln doesn't emote a lot he's
not talkative in general um and if he's
really enjoying something he doesn't
gush you kind of have to like really
listen closely and realized that oh this
is this is middle child Lincoln's
version of gushing we're we're on the
lift going up we had done like a few
runs on the first day and he was like
Dad what do you think the best thing
ever is to do and I was like this is
pretty good I don't know maybe this is
up here he like I think this is it wow
that's a hearty endorsement it that it
makes me feel good like I you know I
ushered him into this world and he's
like I love it and like you know we
scuba dive together we did that in New
Zealand we're doing the snowboarding
together um I got him into the one
wheels just like uh shepher does and um
did he say that one one Wheeling
translates well to snowboarding because
that's what yeah Shephard has read
that's why he wants to do it because a
one whee fiend yeah it it certainly
helps I mean you still don't have the
edge The Edge
experience um with snowboarding you got
to know your it's all about you know
carving on your edges and stuff but it's
the same feel mhm so yeah I think it
definitely helps um but I was like yeah
what what is the best thing like the
best experience and the more I thought
about I was like well you know a
mountain bike a lot it's convenient I
don't have to drive like five hours to
do it like I do for snowboarding I don't
have to um you know scuba diving is
really amazing it's
otherworldly but you do just like you do
a day trip it has a couple of
Dives and so you're dedicating this
whole day for like two or three 45 to 60
Minute experiences but by the time you
get to like a mountain and if if it's
decent or good conditions not even like
great and most
fabulous it's it may be the best
activity it's just so much fun to be on
the Mountain Man to be snowboarding we
had so much fun I I love it I'm
realizing how it's so I'm ranking
snowboarding I'm agreeing with Lincoln I
think I'm ranking it number one for me
would you say
activities with clothes on okay that is
what I I was like son I was like I just
wanted to close activities with cloth
on I think that snowboarding is now my
number one well I think mountain biking
you can do a lot with your clothes on
may be my number two but you know why
don't you just say nonsexual yeah I'll
just say nonsexual outside of the World
of Sex snowboarding is it for you better
than
eating oh 100% no yeah yeah yeah yeah
number one sex number two eating and
then we get into the physical activities
for me for okay for me I'll put sex as
number one I'm going to put snowboarding
as number two I'm going to put and I
want to hear your list I'm going to put
mountain biking at number three is a
close shave above
scuba diving because scuba diving is
just so
amazing uh I don't know if I'm prepared
to make a list here you got to make a
list because I want to know what's and
you can put food on this list I'm
putting food on my list scuba diving put
food after mountain biking and then a oh
definitely a Smash Burger that we just
talked about I would I
would the the way that you feel about
clothes that you would wear the same
outfit every day is the way that I feel
about
food I I would I would give up as long
as I liked it I would eat my smoothie
every day every meal and just get it
over with as much I do enjoy food but I
don't I I observe how people who really
enjoy food like you well I'm jealous of
you when you really enjoy food it can
make discipline very difficult I don't
yeah I I I don't have that so then it
come then after that I'm going to put
food no I will say no I'm I think I'm
going to put APS before food you can't
just eat Smash Burgers all day though
what I'm saying is that not a cumulative
experience
but when you get that Smash Burger and
when you take that first bite and then
like maybe the next four to six
bites that period of time which I
recognize is for me it's about 45
seconds we're talking sub minute here
that's an incredible M now I can't hold
on were we are we talking about sex now
yeah yeah I can't SU
sustain talking about Burgers I can't
sustain that for very long so scuba
diving cumulative experience is is much
more pleasurable time I don't you know I
don't know how to measure that it's like
measuring like what is work you know is
it the amount of weight that you move
over a I don't there is a definition I
can't remember because we make internet
videos now but like the amount of time
that you put in force over distance or t
time yeah time right I don't know I
don't know so pleasure can be measured
in some sort of similar by some Metric
that time so but we are now pleasure
forever we are now ranking pleasure
experiences and you know what if Jenna
Jamie if y'all if you want to develop
your list you can you can throw it in
here I am now developing mine as my
number
one is sex in every form all the sexuals
okay activities every form every form
that I enjoy I
mean uh okay then I'm going to put
snowboarding now it's starting to seem
weird yeah because now we're adding like
food and naps and everything into it and
then
after after snowboarding I think I'm
going to put I think I'm going to put
naps with my dogs calling thing what
about surfing hold I'm I'm okay I'll
take that into account I've now I'm now
moving naps with my dogs up to number
three and then I'm putting mountain
biking and then I'm putting scuba diving
just on the heels of that and then I'm
putting eating the most pleasurable
foods to
me okay and then after that what about
getting a massage you really like those
then after that I'm going to put a
massage I think you like massages more
than eating based on what I've
seen yeah because I would if I'm really
hungry I won't eat before a massage you
ever tried eating during massage no or I
don't like to eat right before a massage
you don't want to do that well let's get
a restaurant going Smash Burger oh smash
your back bur we Mash your back while
we're smashing the burger SM
smash so it just be Mash mash burgers
and we feed the burger the we feed the
burger through the hole that your face
is coming
down and it but it's toward the second
half of the massage oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah well it's once they well they start
you fa where we're at you start face up
what do you mean where we're at oh our
restaurant typically you start face down
and then turn face up we start the
massage face up and we turn you over
give you a
burger yeah okay yeah you finish with a
milkshake right right through the hole y
we'll look into it so what is your what
is your list who's prepared to go next
uh you can add anything to it what's
your number one this isn't how my brain
works my brain doesn't organize
pleasurable experiences it brings them
all just like burgers or foods to a
place where I am in a certain state so
are you talking about like you want you
like to have a rotation where it's like
you give them all no I'm saying babies
you're giving them all attention my
pleasure receptors are pinged fully at
certain
states you have to rank them dude I
don't have to rank them so catching a
wave and again I'm much more about what
is the moment within the experience
because every single thing that you've
mentioned require like mountain biking
requires a lot of work to get to the top
of the map before you start having fun
that's the problem with it and now it
makes that moment that much more fun
because it's that much more rewarding
but it's hell getting up the mountain
right scuba diving like you said
especially in California especially if
you're on a boat going out to a good
spot the time the preparation the
equipment just getting the
damn nausea uh for that
moment that's what that's why eating is
so much easier because all I got to do
is just go into a
restaurant work I drove there I didn't
climb to it yeah I mean you know what
I'm saying you just have to pay for it
that's the only sacrifice catching a
wave which I'm not a good Surfer you're
better Surfer than me and you're not a
good Surfer I suck at it and I'm worse
than you
and but when you get a wave and like
that time I got a wave and a dolphin
took it with me yes but you're thinking
about just that moment that moment I'm
not I I'm asking you the ceiling rank
activities I can't do it not moments I
can't do it but what I but what I do but
what I am interested
in uh because you're really tempting me
to try to
snowboard I know dude uh but I just
don't you're still so much better at it
than ski I got a lot better at skiing
like can we I want to pause this I got
better at skiing I I want to put a pin
in I'm pretty good at skiing this
convers I want to have this conversation
but I want to finish the ranking
conversation and if you're not going to
participate I will find others who will
I refuse to participate because it would
be dishonest okay can y'all help me out
here I mean you don't however you want
to do it is there something we're
missing what's like I mean well I think
you're right I think most people are
going to put sex first cuz I mean come
on that's just great um I I personally
cannot snowboard or ski I have tried and
don't compare your list of mine I like
jet skiing a lot jet sking is fun jet
skiing is Jamie's number two well no it
goes sex eating jet skiing okay cuz I'm
I'm All About Food like if I could just
like if I could never get fat like I
would just eat constantly would be what
I would do but jet skiing I think it's
really fun cuz you go really fast you're
on a vehicle thing but you're in the
water I like being in the water and I
like going fast and like so that's
really fun and I really liked um uh ATV
writing in the sand dunes that's fun too
man that's super fun and that's like I
mean it took me a minute to get used to
it but once I got used to it you're like
H there's so many possibilities where do
you go jet I got to get Christy on a jet
ski uh San Diego like in Mission Bay
yeah it's like super fun over there you
can go by that big that big boat the
something USS something yeah the yeah
the battleship yeah but you see where my
mind goes as you talk about these things
and and in incidentally this is where
the idea for the Seven Seals of
satisfaction came from in buddy system
season 2 this is this is doing them all
at
once EXA yeah yeah yeah my when you talk
about you you said sex eating and jet
skiing and I immediately just pictured
myself doing all three at the same time
I don't know why right but again I'm
trying to maximize the moment I can't
you start want me to put this into a
list and I just start wanting to combine
the things and create a new experience
that would be awesome yeah if you could
do that if there was a way to stay on
the jet ski and do all of those things
like how amazing would that experience I
think you e both you can definitely eat
on a jet ski what is that called I mean
you talking about and and getting a
massage sex ski is having sex on a jet
ski yeah it's like sex ski brunch yeah
yeah yeah with a mimosa yeah I mean if I
could put drinking in there that's
probably round put drinking okay um
Jenna what are you bringing to this I
put you on the spot here I'm I don't
think I could rank either cuz I'm one of
those like uh if I would rank it I'd
rank it on like the new experiences I've
tried like it's always the new thing
like uh when I when I did like you know
when I when skydiving I was like that
was like the best thing but I did it
once and maybe I'll do it again but it's
not like you don't want to do it every
weekend no no something I would do every
weekend um SE and eating um every
weekend um I I'm a skier I'm not a
snowboarder I tried snowboarding and my
knees um my my knees didn't like me at
all so skiing is much easier on my body
there's something about being on the on
the mountain and it can be so quiet like
the snow makes everything so quiet and
if you're at a space with like good
conditions and not a lot of people I
mean if you can find yourself on a slope
like just on your own it's or just with
like a loved one or something you can't
do that big bear you have to go to
Mammoth to do that we were at Mammoth
and it was uh it was still you know
you're not going to find that much space
but there's just something totally Zen
about it it's totally peaceful and you
can be in your own world and Jenna like
you're saying it's just knowing knowing
the parameters of your body and working
Within like they they you know they
always push ski within your ability you
know you don't want to damage yourself
or hurt other people I mean that's one
of the major ways people get injured is
like collisions but if you can just make
up your mind and I'm really doing a much
better job at this now that I've
Revisited snowboarding like the way that
we used to snowboard was like the way
that you used to snowb balls to the wall
That's I've always exercised caution
because I've been so injury-prone so
yeah I never push it like you did and
but I I felt like if I wasn't achieving
something or getting really good and
pulling off some sort of trick that it
wasn't I wasn't doing it right and now
you know I'm a middle-aged man so are
you jumping at all no uh-uh I'm carving
and I'm just like it feels like I'm
painting with my
feet it's just it it can be the most
relaxing and rewarding and you can get
in into a what's it called a Zone a flow
State you can get into a flow State on a
jet ski I bet yeah as long as there's
like not a lot of boats around I think
so okay but let's talk about this let's
talk about this snowboarding versus
skiing because do you think that Jenna
gets it if if if you had
um if you had gotten you didn't ski as
much much as I did like once we started
skiing I went like maybe five or six
times more than you did yeah I never got
I got where I could do like I mean I
could you know go down a black but it
would be completely pointless for me to
do it because I'm just like skidding the
whole time just go slow but like
Blues you know blues and like whatever
between some places have blue between
blue and black like a blue black thing
but mostly like blues and like not going
too fast like you said just carving I
got where I was having a really good
time I will say though the thing that
never leaves my mind and I think this
might be something that keeps me from
having a great time is just the thought
of eating it yeah running into somebody
having someone run into me hitting a
weird
patch and yeah you know I got when I got
my concussion on the snowboard it was
was because I caught an edge and it's
just like catching an edge with a
snowboard is much easier to do than it
is with skis yeah just like slam you can
get slammed
and well I guess my question before I go
into that it's like if you had gotten
good enough at skiing do you you think
you could reach a flow state or do you
think yeah definitely definitely right
I'm just trying to make sure there's not
a definitive difference because you see
the
people there's something about being in
that position which is like skateboard
SL onewheel SLS surf position yeah
obviously looks cooler because
culturally it's cooler to be in that
position because of the other sports
that are associated with it so that's I
think that's why Shepard wants to do it
that's why Lincoln wants to do it like I
think that teens want to do it because
yeah it's clearly cooler than skiing
right I just want to do it because I can
I'm better at it and I can enjoy it
versus with skiing still try I want to
believe that I'm tempted to believe that
it's more fun fun than skiing but I
can't let myself believe that too much
because I just don't think it's worth I
don't think it's worth the
risk well if we when we go together on a
ski trip now because I can just step in
you're not waiting on me so it's very
similar
experience um the thing that I was
thinking about was like can I snowboard
into old age like you see a bunch of
people a bunch of old guys skiing just
like it's like golf on snow it's like
that there's that many old people skiing
and it that really gives gave me hope
with skiing that it could be a
long-term you know rewarding Adventure
you don't see a lot of 70 plus year olds
snowboarding but and that must be
because of the the the way the injuries
I don't know I think or is it just
because it's less of them do it to begin
with I think it's because the sport is
younger yeah they just haven't got the
old snowboarders haven't happened yet so
that's now my hope you know I mean to to
be able to ski or snowboard or whatever
like any kind of type of like physical
activity and it was very much on my mind
driving back yesterday the thing I like
about it is that it says okay it tells
me this is something I can work towards
in terms of Fitness like I got to stay
at a certain level of Fitness so that I
can continue to enjoy this activity that
apparently is my number two activity
you know up until like I'm 80 years old
so so I got you're
75 like the consequences of a of a
fall increase with age and because don't
talk me out of it talk talk me into
fitness I'm just saying because that's
that was my point if you get hurt
snowboarding it's probably going to be
because some jack leg who just learned
how to ski runs into you yeah we got to
learn to be very
defensive sometimes you don't see him
yeah I know I know but I I think I
could right now I'm just saying it it
aligns my motivations you know to enjoy
mountain biking you got to be a certain
level of Fitness to enjoy you know to
enjoy oh yeah snowboarding so like I got
I got to start doing I got to start
doing some more weights or
something yeah
M so that's where I'm at I we had a
great time I did not I ate it a few
times but it's mostly like coming coming
off the
lift or so when you come off the lift is
the same thing you got one you got one
you got a front foot in yeah back foot
just kind of goes on the board
yeah I'm pretty good at that though
those are the things that I kind of
forgot about and then when I went skiing
I was very grateful like getting off the
lift is so such a breeze and then you
just you just keep going yeah and also
when you get to the flat Parts yep that
that's it's a breeze I'm fine with
getting off the lift but it is it
requires
concentration the flat Parts there's no
way around it you know I can easily pop
my foot out and then start you know kick
push type thing but but can skiers and
snowboarders really hang I mean that's
the thing if we go on the mountain can
we really be friends I think it's going
to be like the burger thing I think you
go down I go down we we meet later and
talk about it yeah I don't think we can
be seen on the lift together yeah it's a
Fox and the Hound situation yeah yeah
well you missed my party because of this
it's totally worth it I think but then
Christy was telling me that like she was
like there were people everywhere first
of all like the amount of turnout like
I've never seen as many people at your
house as christe described she was
like there were people everywhere it
wasn't like there wasn't a place you
could go to like have a little space it
was a good crowd I was like first of all
that's a good party when you got you
were concerned about turnout because it
was a New Year's Eve party that then got
moved a month later and then people
didn't even know well not a month later
two weeks later
um so you had a good turnout well so the
original conception of the party was
Jesse's idea and you know I have this um
as I've talked about on this very show I
have this desire to do these events that
are not just normal parties you know and
I felt like when Jesse had this idea for
a New Year's Eve party and she was like
and it was a last minute thing at the
time because it was two weeks until New
Year's and she was like let's just have
a party with just whoever happens to be
in town during New Year's Eve which in
La it's not a lot of people most people
are from somewhere else they go back
home whatever
traveling and then once we started kind
of putting
together the list we we started
realizing this is a really interesting
mix of people because it's people that
she knows that I don't really know
people that I know that she doesn't
really know people that I know through
what I do but also our F Collective
friends and parents of kids that our
kids are friends
with and I've never mixed that those
groups of people other than maybe like
my birthday 40th birthday party which
was you know also had a bunch of
mythical people it was massive but I
haven't had a party like this in a
really long time and I was a little bit
like oh well this guy's going to come
and you know there there was at least 15
people
that had never been to our house before
and had
never had maybe
met the other half of the couple re and
Jesse once or none so how what was the
total that was there then 60 no no no no
Christie made it seem like there was
like 60 people there Max 40 oh okay well
and you you had a bar you had an open
bar but it was coffee well we had a we
had a coffee bar because Jesse did that
for Lock's graduation party where you
can get somebody who's just going to
make coffee drinks like people like to
drink night coffees uh well they
certainly did at Lock's graduation party
now they had decaf everything okay uh
that's a good idea the coffee bar was
not popular enough to do it again that
was the conclusion we came to and then
we had like our little bar area just had
like wine champagne
beer liquor and you can mix it whatever
you can kind of make your own thing okay
I think I would actually do a bartender
who was making drinks next time versus a
and then they can make a coffee drink
too maybe I don't want to make a I mean
maybe Espress so Martini I don't know I
don't want to I want to speak for him
that's what I would have um I'll get to
the main event in a second mhm uh which
is sort of the taking a baby step
towards what some people might call a
salon type event you know what I'm
saying like that's what they would call
out here right like a salon a salon is
like when that's where my grandma gets
her hair did people gather and then
there's like something that happens from
a person or and we talked about the uh
like the pasta PowerPoint idea taking
something like that and doing something
like a group activity that was fun
um well because it was a New Year's Eve
party we originally were planning on
ringing in the new
year that wasn't happening so what I did
that got some good feedback was I just
put uh I went on YouTube and got like
the late 70s early 80s and some 90s Dick
Clark's rocking New Year's Eve whatever
ever like they're just on YouTube and
just put them on a playlist and so it
was all these old acts and stuff playing
Just without the sound on because we had
a playlist going the whole time with
music but it was like you got to see
like oh there's Alabama playing the 1985
Rocking New Year's Eve on mute on mute
that's cool so that was a nice little
touch but you to but I heard that you
had some synchronicity with between the
Dick
Clark thing and like a pseudo countdown
uh that was accidental and I'll tell
that story in a second well Christy
chrisy said Rhett T Rhett was playing
this old Dick Clark New Year's Eve
countdown and he timed it y to where the
countdown and we all did the countdown
the countdown led to like 10 minutes
to what time was the main event 10:30
10:30 10:40 yeah she was like until like
10:30 and then the countdown
went Main and then it went straight into
the main event I was like total luck oh
that that was I was really impressed by
that total luck total luck
yeah hey you you fooled her man you
fooled everybody yep I'm glad you know
sometimes things work out sometimes you
just got to start something and things
work out Things fall in the place that's
what you should have planned I was
giving you so much credit uh yeah it was
all intentional L did everybody count
down like oh yeah oh yeah they did
now the thing that I noticed and of
course our friend gar was there and gar
is uh very observant the most observant
person that I know in terms of just like
social dynamics and stuff um he he is
better known as the batting stance guy
you know he's uh he observes literally
can do do like every batting stance of
every major league baseball player that
you care to know about and uh it's a
very Niche talent that you know the MLB
loves him because he's so good at this
they'll bring him into the locker room
before a game and he and they teams call
him in because he's he's he's freaking
incredible and like that audience is so
primed for his particular talent that no
one else
has and there are times
when gar will break this out at the
party not because he's like he wants to
do it but because somebody who knows he
can do it starts egging him on I'll get
to that in a moment but gar came up to
me an hour and a half into the party and
he was like you know how gar would
communicate this he was like well done
he was like good party this group of
people that you have assembled is like
he's like there's not a you don't go to
a lot of parties like this where you've
got like that couple is
obviously friends of you know parents of
one of the kids' friends yeah different
vibe than oh that person is from the
entertainment industry and these are
very different Vibes and you usually go
to parties where it's like one or the
other yeah and we just were like these
are our people are our friends and let's
just bring them all together and it's
like it seems like everyone really it
worked dug that Vibe of like this person
has this really interesting job that's
not in the industry but industry people
get tired of hanging out with industry
people because they tend to
be vampires leeches shallow status
people right and so uh he was kind of
talking about that dynamic because you
know he's with his connections he ends
up experiencing these types of
gatherings and he was just like having a
blast seeing people interact but
then uh Jess and Jesse is doing this
thing where she'll like go up and be
like this is so and so and uh he's a you
know Grammy award-winning like stuff
that no one wants to say grammy
award-winning producer and this is so
and so and he's a so and he's an
imagineer at Disney and she's like
she'll like say that so then they've
broken the ice and don't have to have
that conversation about right right
their uh yeah and then they start
talking and so but then when she goes up
to my new friend Jake who you haven't
met yet she's like uh this is this this
is your potential golfin buddy yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh it's going to happen uh
we're working it out we're working on
the date right now he's like you can be
so old and do that yeah
exactly Jesse was like this is Jake he's
a musician this is uh
gar he can do batting
stances what she did not know is that
Jake played division one college
baseball and is a freaking baseball fre
that he brought is also a baseball guy
oh yes that just set it off and then
there this was not the main event by the
way this is this is in my hall and
they're just calling out people and you
know I I know a few baseball
players Dale Murphy you know what I'm
saying like I I know like the all stars
throughout the years Wade bugs but what
I don't know is the the specific ones
where someone is trying to throw him off
and throw somebody they're just thinking
about because they know baseball and
then he can do it perfectly I'm
entertained by that because I don't it's
blowing mind because I don't because I'm
observing the niche coming together and
they were flipping out they had the best
time because he was doing the thing and
he was going into all his stuff where he
emphasizes certain things it was just it
was a beautiful
moment but yes can't believe you didn't
plan the countdown so yeah back Main
Event the the the the thing it was you
did plan to have a main event which I
was like what time did that
happen and Christy was like yeah 10 it
was like 10:30 I was like that was smart
because then every it gives people a
reason to stay at the party it's kind of
like the people who were looking for a
reason like oh I showed up and now I'm
probably going to go at like 10: now
they're like why I'm I stay till 10:30
because of the the you know what that's
about to happen that was is really smart
right you got everybody sticking around
because there's something it's like the
cutting of the cake at the wedding
reception yes well you got to stay until
they C I don't even like cake now you
got to stay until they C the cake and
there was a little bit of a preamble
because um so we asked Robert the
mythical magician that you may know from
Good Mythical Morning
appearances uh and I think he's done did
he do he did a did he do a society
special too or did he did yeah that's
what he did yeah yeah
um so and he did a party that you were
at DJing yeah he did Laura's graduation
party like a month earlier um and so we
were like yeah let's have a magician
because why not because how how often do
you go to a party at somebody's house
and they have a freaking magician not
often no and uh more often than a guy
who can do any batting stance but still
not that often and I also the funny
thing about it is I was telling gar this
I was
like I think our connection to Robert
actually started with us it started the
the very beginning of it was us making
fun of
magicians yeah because we we've
established that we have we've made fun
of magicians on this show yeah not that
we don't appreciate it but like we kind
of poked fun at him and then the whole
thing started with Stevie telling us
that she had been to a she had seen a
zoom musician so we magician so we were
like we're going to have that for our
Christmas
party that's what it was and so he he
did the mythical Christmas party in
2021 completely over it was all all zoom
and we did it because we like to do
things that are a little bit weird and
make people feel awkward but what ended
up happening is he did such a good job
yeah that everybody was just like I just
unabashedly love that yeah and so then
he just kind of became a part of when we
need a magician we go to
Robert and uh so Robert came early and
just walked around the party and we just
kind of go out to a group of people and
start doing close magic which is a cool
thing to happen at a party yeah you know
you didn't expect it like who's this guy
and all of a sudden he's got a deck of
cards and he's doing something stealing
your wallet and um only to give it back
to you and then he did it we did a thing
so you know how our living room has
steps that go up into the main part of
the house yeah so it's kind of like
sunken yeah so we put him on the top of
the steps like a like a stage everybody
sat in the living room and we were able
to fit every there was a couple people
who didn't come in uh one of our friends
which I will remain nameless who you'll
be able to guess was like I'm
uncomfortable with magicians so I'm not
going to I'm not going to I'm not going
to watch this which made total sense to
me and there's so a few people didn't go
in but it was there was enough room and
uh he did like a I don't half hour
show and people just people just love it
because it was kind of unexpected gives
you a focal point yeah and it was just
not only to stick around but and then
once he was
done there are people there's a certain
group of people who are like well we
don't stay at people's homes past
midnight MH we're going home you know
60% but then there's the 40% who are
like well as long as you guys are here
and up we'll still we're sticking around
yeah so like the last person left at
like 1:00 a.m. or something like that so
it was a lot way past my
bedtime well I hate I missed it you know
if I wasn't doing the number one thing
on my list that wasn't sex uh yeah
magician parties I he didn't rank that
anywhere nope nowhere at all that I
heard I don't I mean I still don't think
I am but jet ski is now definitely on my
list but we immediately the next morning
were talking about the things that we
would do differently to make it easier
on ourselves just to do it but how much
fun we had and then I got so many texts
from people the next day who were just
like I had such a great time that was a
great time love getting to know your
other friends like what I I was kind of
nervous about that whole like this
couple Only Knows Jesse hey you know
what people come to a party they can
meet people it's not it's you you you
know well but you set the table but
everybody's got to eat yeah I was just
very happy with the fact that people
just kind of just did their own thing
and like everybody was talking and
having conversations and everyone stayed
and so the only
change is no coffee bar
more alcohol which who's going to argue
with that I think a a bartender instead
of a coffee bar you can't go with a
magician again oh hell no not nothing
against magicians but that was just that
I'm not I'm going to mix it up yeah yeah
yeah maybe maybe a um I don't think
mechanical bow it doesn't tournament it
doesn't have to be one focal point it
could be we're going to do this thing
where it's more like the moth where uh
we would like you to prepare a story
that is about this kind of thing and the
first 15 people to sign up oh can tell a
5 minute story or a 3 minute story or
something like that and then so then
it's like well if I don't want to tell a
story I don't have to but people who
want to tell stories are encouraged to
do so and so then we have a moment where
everyone is like entertaining one
another versus it being one person
interesting the other thing I'm going to
do differently is we we got all our food
from PTO which was great because it's
all like finger food you know mhm
but we got we got it and we served it
and we heated it up and so there was
just
like you know I feel like you got the
food situation we got to think about
that a little
bit think I think in order to really
focus I think you got to get it catered
I think put your kids in tuxes man I
think you got shepher in tux like you
got to go the lowest level of catering I
don't want like people come I don't want
to be fancy people coming around with
plates of food I'm just saying that
like you don't want to make the food hot
yeah I'm worrying about switching the
things out but like man I hate I missed
it man you got to come to the next one
it'll be well it'll be planned well in
advance okay okay you think you're GNA
get people to tell stories oh that's
just an idea I mean first of
all in Los Angeles man it's plenty of St
you got all these people and the thing
is is that you don't just get the people
who come from an entertainment
background to tell a stor you get the
person who just has a really
interesting you might have to job
experience and then I might have to give
a little I might have to give him a
little call and give him a little nudge
and be like hey you might have to narrow
down the topic oh no no it would just be
it would be do you have a story about
pudding just to to use the the you know
that might be a little too uh that's a
little too narrow but you want me to
share five stories do you have a
near-death
experience okay you know and so then we
serve like death by chocolate cake at
the end and you've got so it's a death
theme and it's just like near death
experience you do some kind of them
that's a good Halloween
theme maybe that's the October party is
a near-death experiences yeah and nobody
has to dress
up you could if you want to but you
could if you wanted to but that's not
the theme of the party right well I
don't I'm making no commitments making
no commitments at this point well
neither am I then I might show up or I
might be snowboarding got to hear about
the Deets the
details um I think my recommendation
this this week if I'm going to wreck it
up it's my turn to give a
recommendation is um make your
list yeah you know it's it's good to
know what you enjoy like I said I mean I
know some people are against it and you
know what it's not for everybody to like
make a list maybe the thing but to
identify you don't have to rank them an
un maybe it's an unranked pool of
activities and you might say you know
what I need to add a few on there or my
it's a vision board my a vision yeah
creative if you don't want to make a
list make a vis Vis Board of pleasure
yes a pleasure board and it and one of
your things may be trying something new
just once like Jenna said and then
you're like then you're like oh yeah I
need to come up with something new I
made a vision board last night you made
a one last night I did yeah oh I had I
had some friends over we had a games and
arts and crafts and it a bunch of
girlfri doing Jen is having curated
parties it was a curated party yeah and
like some of us like did our arts and
crafts and made vision boards um a
friend of mine loves making jewelry so
she brought some of her jewelry stuff
and then we like all sat down and played
like dominoes for a while and yeah it
was a blast it was this a Life vision
board a or what I'm saying a pleasure
vision board it was uh it was a year
vision board of yeah things that I um of
things that I want to come into my life
and like the things I want to do okay
yeah so kind of I guess it is a pleasure
board but for the for the year okay all
right all right all right I like
it I kind of want to see it but I'll
show I'll I'll send I'll show you a
photo I mean I if people want to see it
I'll yeah I picture it like
um it's like a vacation bible school
felt board um no it's so much better oh
it's better than felt you don't have to
you don't have to publish it but if
you're going to show it to us now we'll
just describe it in general
terms I'm not trying to publish your
personal vision board I mean there's
nothing okay I'm just going to describe
it um yes it's it's like cut out felt
it's felt pieces on like a it's like you
know how felt sticks to felt and if
you're a child and you go to like not
Vacation Bible School yeah it's okay if
you want to defend yourself you got to
get back on mic It's
Paper I would say it's exactly like a
felt Vacation Bible I'm just I'm just
joking that that's a CL
there's some velvet where did you get
these these things it's like an adult
collage did you print them out it is it
is an adult collage yeah it's exactly
what I made and you didn't leave any
white space I didn't well it was also
the the board that I used was something
that I used for Arts like a little art
thing like years ago that it you know
you just keep those boards and you're
like I'm not going to throw it away
that's wasteful so I just like did
something over top of it you know how
how big how painters always paint over
their ma masterpieces with another
Masterpiece I'm comparing myself to a
masterpiece painter right now my your
old Vision it should be replaced by your
new vision yeah
yeah I love it yeah it's mod pod collage
and there's a my pod collage and um
there's a in Pasadena there's um a used
arts and craft store where you can go
and get like super inexpensive like
anything you need arts and crafts like
half a pencil um yeah that but it's
mostly like you know um a crown set that
was used like once or twice or like one
thing is missing that totally makes
sense and it's like and um all of the
magazines that I got I got for free
there um and they had a bunch of just
like crafting magazines that had really
pretty like art and visual stuff love
can you make one of these for me um you
kind of diffus well well I've already
given you my list yeah that's true
you've given me the list and I'll I'll
need color paletes and I mean you're
going to it's part of your job yeah I'll
make a vision your hour it's not like
I'm asking you to like yeah during
during work do it as a hobby I mean this
is a you know this is you will be paid
for this you will be paid
for that's a good
service all right well there well I I
think that's my Rec now get Jenna to
make you a vision for okay all
right no it's not oh that was F
congratulations on your party man
congratulations on
gosh I wish I I wish I could do both I
wish I could be to snowboarding party at
the same time well maybe that's what we
do we'll talk at you next week in the
meantime call
us and leave us a
voicemail about anything that we would
that you basically you're daring us to
respond oh okay 1888 Ear Pod
one hey R link this is Richard from
South Carolina I just want to say I
heard Rett mention to eat roblock
broccoli whenever you have the
opportunity and I just want to say I
appreciate you saying that because me
and my wife are eating more raw broccoli
than we ever have before thank
you